my struts the year what do we got to
look forward to so hello folks welcome
to counseled geeks
we haven't done a roundtable in a while
but I have Ryan joining me who is not
the one I would have expected between
the two oh yes what could I possibly
have to occupy my time besides this well
I actually had somebody ask like and I
got a comment on another video if you
expect like where are the other guys in
the council I'm like with their
respective newborns right I do
and we do want to wish Paul Sorvino
happy birthday as we record this and it
is what should we be with him right now
instead of recording this tech with them
but yes so we're gonna we're gonna do
what we haven't done in a while which is
have a roundtable and we are gonna look
at the geeky ish movies coming out in
the last three months of the year
October November December on October the
6th Bladerunner 2049 wow that is much
earlier than I thought
I did not think that was this year no
it's it's coming it's coming up before
we get into the movie specifically I
find myself wondering if in the wake of
them like waiting until basically three
weeks before it opened to really kick
the Wonder Woman campaign into high gear
if Studios I'm pretty sure this is a
Warner Brothers film are starting to
reassess whether it is necessary to do
like a months-long ramped up to a film
or not it's certainly possible I mean
they might be rethinking how they do
their promotion putting more money
closer to the release which honestly I
would be all in favor of because I get
over my being pumped for something six
months before the thing comes out at
this point like even the ones I'm
looking forward to that we're going to
talk about of which this is one I I saw
the first teaser for this probably about
six months ago I know very little about
this movie other than
the caste I remember seeing the first
teaser I don't think guy I don't
remember seeing anything since then I
never thought it needed a sequel like
when they were saying we're gonna do
another one I was like okay now what I
have seen based on the director Dennis
Villanueva
uh he's French so it's Denis Villeneuve
okay forget what I was gonna say I
trusted the the vision that would I
think this could be a very good movie I
am in joy I am looking forward to seeing
its when it comes to HBO or some sort of
streaming platformer it's it's pretty
much the directors involvement that and
that made me from skeptical to hopeful
okay because when I because I hadn't
seen anything he's not like I still
haven't seen prisoners and I haven't
seen Sicario and I yeah all these things
I've been meaning to get around to but I
saw a rival okay and loved it and then
like oh this is the guy doing the next
Blade Runner okay I'm so like he
addressed that he he it is not his
intention to directly answer the
overhanging question of whether or not
the Harrison Ford character is a
replicant which means he understands the
ambiguity of that is is a is a is an
important element to the first film so
am I good that shows me you understand
this the the value and the strength of
this original film whether or not you
can recreate it I don't know we'll see
but I'm I it's it's his involvement
specifically because on premise I was
going
but well once I saw a rival I was like
okay then based on that I'm assuming
tomorrow we'll find out that he's been
hired to direct Star Wars Episode nine
which I would be absolutely down for
this movie might be very very good I
won't say it in the theater but I hope
it's very good I look forward to seeing
it eventually down the road I really had
no idea it was coming out in this this
soon from when we're recording this
completely snuck up on me
yeah rest of October's bit of a mixed
bag I'm sure the ones the next time
gonna say I would be surprised if you
even heard of but I have reasons I want
to talk about it many huh so on October
the 13th there are two movies coming out
that I want to bring up the first is
happy deathday Friday the 13th release
in the month of October yes it is and
happy deathday you say happy deathday
romantic comedy I'm a stone and let's
say Jake Gyllenhaal okay so it is
Groundhog Day as a horror movie and
there's the eyes okay so this girl she
wakes up it's her birthday she goes to a
party she is murdered at the party and
after she is murdered she wakes up and
it is that Saint morning but she has
full memory of what happened and she
tries to avoid what happened and she
still gets murdered and she keeps
getting killed no matter what she does
like she gets in a car and drives us far
away from where she knows she got killed
as possible and she still gets killed by
the same masked person and then and then
wakes up that same day and it keeps
repeating it resets every time she gets
killed and she has to figure out what I
must stop getting killed by Jake
Gyllenhaal yeah yes it is no it's a
bunch of unknown actor I mean it's one
of those things that is sold completely
on the premise have you seen the trailer
have you seen it I have seen the trailer
I found the trailer quite intriguing
there was something really interesting
about her reactions because much like so
how is how is this different basically
from like a final destination where you
just have the same character being
killed over and over again like what
what
to come down to it and whether or not it
works will depend on the actress
unfortunate I don't know from anything
but if she can make it work the bits I
saw her in the trailers like her
reactions as she's realizing what's
going on feel very real and very
human-like and like I said her first
thing is he isn't like oh I have to
solve the mystery of my own killing it's
oh I have another [ __ ] I'm driving
that's as far as friggin possible for me
what that's what any rational human
being would yes and yet somehow this
killer still finds her which to me also
ups the injuries like okay that
something really crazy is gone beyond
just the just the present the beyond
just the loop there's something really
weird going on with this killing now
it's the sort of set of that could very
easily have a very disappointing end a
climatic or nonsensical and search to
what's going on but the trailer would
have me intrigued okay I hope it's good
that's so the other one I'll mention
coming out that same weekend is
basically Jackie Chan doing taken so
it's called the it's called the
foreigner okay it's set in England
Jackie Chan's daughter is killed in an
explosion in a terrorist bombing and he
then targets appears Brosnan who is a
government official who Jackie Chan
believes knows who the people who
planted the bomb are okay
Pierce Bronson won't give that
information to him now the trail makes
it look like maybe he's in our maybe
he's just doing his job as a government
person and not giving names to someone
who obviously wants to do vigilante
justice but he then starts terrorizing
and planting bombs around Pierce Brosnan
and his people trying to get him to give
up the names and of course Jackie Chan
has a whole his character has a whole
you know special ops training background
and all that stuff but this is dead
there is no hint of the of the jovial
chuckling comedic side of Jackie Chan
it's gone it sounds interesting I hope
it's good I hope it finds an audience
certainly any any movie with
non-caucasian I hope it finds an
audience because it seems like there
aren't as many of those but is it my
movie now yeah I mean I'm also hoping
that Jackie Chan is really able to sell
it because I mean the man still doesn't
there are clearly action scenes they
show up in the trailer but at the same
time he's getting to that age where he
can't that he that can't be what right
what he is the only thing he's there to
do so I'm hoping that it works in terms
of giving him more acting cred
I've seen precious few of his movies by
which maybe two um and there was always
the Kung Fu laced with a bit of comedy
in like physical and that was this thing
and you know and he was great at that
but he can't do that right sure the next
weekend are you familiar with this was
the sordid history of geo storm no okay
now this is the directorial debut of
Dean Devlin best known as a producer and
working during Roland Emmerich's heyday
he proposed Independence Day Stargate
and that god-awful Godzilla now it was
shot four years ago was apparently
horrible but was so friggin expensive
the studio I forgot my studio was was
not prepared to write it off and instead
ordered a ton of very expensive reshoots
to try and salvage this thing the
premise is that it's the near future and
there is a satellite that controls the
weather but somebody takes it over and
starts using natural disasters to they
weaponize the weather they weaponize the
weather I was my favorite GI Joe episode
and I think they actually weaponize the
weather to try and kill the president
I'm not 100% on that one I guess I guess
I would like to know more about why the
first cut they thought was so horrific
was it script directing just all of the
above wake up I don't know I mean the
interface
director if it's a prodigy of roland
emmerich the entire premise is just so
dated it's not like oh well that's a
good idea maybe he's just weak as the
Darger's like no this whole idea sounds
awful
like everything about this sounds
terrible what are you they should have
just signed a deal with Hasbro and made
it a GI Joe movie that's yeah that's
that but they didn't then thus it's
coming to theaters also coming out that
same weekend the latest attempt to give
a go at reviving the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre franchise we get Leatherface I
don't care about this I know I here's
one thing there's one thing about the
premise I'm like okay that could make
for an interesting like student short
take on the idea I don't think we need a
movie out of it but apparently at least
part of the movie deals with like three
escaped violent juveniles okay and one
of them is going to eventually become
Leatherface but it doesn't make clear
which one of them it is I mean okay that
might be kind of interesting cuz I never
really cared for the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre it's considered a masterpiece
of horror I thought I didn't like it but
whatever if they're actually managed to
hide which character becomes Leatherface
well then some horrible things out there
that these three people despise them and
it's just whoever's left standing I
still don't care I don't care either but
I would say props do them for throwing
uh at least once rolling a little twist
an interesting idea when they didn't
have to [ __ ] so now you might have found
yourself thinking isn't there a release
date that's closer to Halloween than
that well there is but it has been
staked out by jigsaw which which is the
attempt to revive the Saw franchise
almost stolen Gyllenhaal yes absolutely
you are nailing this I actually have
only ever seen the first Saw movie
that's one more than I think I thought
was fine for what it was which is a
basically a bottle story mm-hmm I know
like the gist of what goes on after that
and the franchise because I found it
mildly interesting but I never watched
any of them yeah the premise the torture
parts amulets yeah okay that's like be
the one thing I always found interesting
it's the reason I would look up the
Wikipedia entries is the killer the
jigsaw killer dies in the third film and
they made seven of them and I found it
interesting the the hoops that the
series kept jumping through to explain
the continuing impact of this dead guy
cuz he doesn't come back okay from he
dies in the third film and stays dead
but his legacy but his legacy like he
had stuff set up to happen after his
death he had an apprentice he had this
he had that all right well coming out
that same weekend I believe in a
slightly more limited release Professor
Marston and the Wonder women oh okay so
this is the story of the William Moulton
Marston the man who created Wonder Woman
and the two women who influenced the
creation of that character being his
wife and their meet their mutual
girlfriend polyamorous relationship and
he's being played by oh that is a good
question somebody who may not think to
play this every Bart I think it's it's
not like Luke Evans but it's somebody
similar see that that is exactly the
name that was coming to my mind but I'm
not sure if that is who it is it is no
it is Lucas Lucas Lucas I'm interested
in this one and actually additionally
and I hadn't even realized this it is
written and directed by a woman okay so
I mean I think obviously this thing was
in was in the works and was pretty much
shot and was in post-production when
Wonder Woman came out boy did they get
lucky that that movie hit as big as it
did I think there's there is a much
bigger interest in this story than there
would have been otherwise and that that
takes care of October we get into
November and one of the two movies I
know you're
you gotta go see thor ragnarok uh I'm
excited for this one I am too I do it is
one that I keep forgetting is coming up
but that's less because my excitement is
died down but more because I have cut
myself off from the marketing that's
cool like I think I I only saw the first
full trailer and then I'm like awesome
I'm sold and I've stopped since then I
think there was only one big the
comic-con trailer since then and then
there been like international cuts yes
like the other footage none of which I'm
not much it's mostly the comic-con
trailer which was outstanding as good as
the original teaser was the comic I was
slightly different energy different
music but also really really good taiko
YTD the director has just a really cool
ballsy direction that they just let them
go for it what I'm hoping is I mean I
know I'm pretty sure Avengers infinity
war or Avengers 4 will be the swan song
at least for this version of Captain
America and I think Chris Evans and
Robert Downey jr. are done or they're
gonna be way too expensive I think it
would be in their interest to have at
least one of the original folks stick
around for whatever the new iteration of
Avengers is and Chris Hemsworth would be
really good for that
yeah beyond that like the movie just
looks really excited I'm really
interested in the way they depict the
Hulk in this one I'm excited to see
Valkyrie Tessa tops its Victor I really
liked her and Creed so I'm excited for
this one
um I also take it what you said it's
gonna be the shortest Marvel movie based
on the cut they have right now I think
in terms of runtime so I think it's just
gonna be a brisk just I sign down for a
breezy good time exactly so not too long
have been 2 weeks after that Justice
League as as recently as a week ago I'm
hearing conflicting reports about whose
movie this is Wow
some people are saying jut like 50% as
much as 50% of the final cut will be new
stuff that Joss Whedon has written or
directed and some people are saying that
really he's just doing some pickups and
stuff it's still definitely the vision
of
Schneider like you can't get this
message straight at this point this late
in the game here's here's what I here's
my understanding and basically it's me
they're both kind of right Joss Whedon
has done major work on it and there have
been major research to the point that I
believe Josephine is actually getting a
writing credit that having been said he
himself and most of the people are still
saying this is still intended to be
Snyder's vision so my belief is that he
has done major rework on it but still
aiming to deliver a movie that is in the
spirit and with the intent of what
Snyder was trying to do not slavish to
the point that he's like oh this was
Snyder's script and even though it's bad
I'm gonna use it obviously not that but
I think he is still most likely going to
deliver a movie that is not what the
Joss Whedon Justice League would be
here's the comparison film that I can
make it it's the only one I can think of
that feels like a valid comparison for
the situation and that's AI because it
was very much Stanley Kubrick's you know
vision and Steven Spielberg a very
different director trying to deliver
what another director would have done
and the result being really weird I'm
gonna put the same asterisk on this that
I put on Wonder Woman which is that if
the reviews are are positive and I mean
solidly positive I will probably
actually go in the go and see it in the
theater despite having gone on record
previously saying I wasn't going to do
that because I if things look like their
turn they have turned around and become
what I said I wanted them to be I'm not
gonna be pig in and go
well I said back in March that I wasn't
gonna go watch it so neither I'm not
that petty I will see it if it well I
may actually fixed it I am that's what I
said that's why I'm holding my arms like
that you just mom there you go
in keeping with us like if they if they
sort of course correct and they're
turning this around between Wonder Woman
Justice and Justice League they have
some momentum driving they still of 13
months before their next movie
yes yes there is Aquaman don't come on
until Christmas of the next year on the
8th of December there is Guillermo del
Toro's new movie the shape of water I
don't know anything about it ok well
there's a trailer that's out so it's
almost like an Abe Sapien solo movie ok
it's not literally that because he's not
working at Pella boy universe but it
deals I believe it's a period piece I
think it's the 50s it's definitely not
modern times but it deals with this
woman who is mute who gets a job just
cleaning like being a janitor are made
in this government facility and one of
the things that's in there is this fish
man that they are observing and studying
and some of them are arguing they should
be cutting open and examining and she
builds a relationship with this thing
through nonverbal communication because
it doesn't speak she's mute and they
find other ways to bond this could be
really interesting and this I'm sure
mine is the minority opinion I didn't
like Pacific Rim I just I was kind of
bored by it
it's just wasn't my thing I didn't
really like either of the Hellboy movies
and I didn't like Blade 2 and I never
saw Pan's Labyrinth so for me EML del
Toro is not a draw in any way all right
get out I like you a lot I do think he
gets overrated in some circles Pacific
Rim I found to be fun but some people
really lost their minds over I wasn't
entirely sure why but to my to my
interests and my sensibility he's never
made an uninteresting movie and he's
never made a movie that I wished I
hadn't bothered to see I mean probably
his weakest movies again to my opinion
were Kronos which is his first movie
which is still visually beautiful and
really interesting and mimic which was
his first Hollywood film which is kind
of dumb but done very stylishly and
still worth seeing once if for no other
reason that you can see Josh Brolin get
gutted by John
cockroach that's not gonna be in the
Avengers as for nice Wow I mean maybe
it'll get omage we never know also
coming out that same weekend I believe
in limited release but I want to bring
it up anyway the disaster artist tell me
how familiar are you with the room is
this the the guy's name Tommy was summer
so I know the legend of this yeah okay
the disaster artist was originally a
book written by the co star of the room
about the experience of making lorem the
movie the disaster artist is directed by
and starring in the role of Tommy Wiseau
do you tell me what's up James Franco
okay
I like James Franco I okay interesting I
think this could be amazing it could
also be insufferable if it gets if they
just gets too happy with itself for
existing but what do you think of the
odds of Tommy Wiseau directing Star Wars
Episode nine well we get to the big
release of December which is of course
Star Wars Episode eight the last Jedi
directed by Rian Johnson who most likely
will direct episode bad way which I mean
obviously I haven't seen last Jedi yet
but I have I have a heck of a lot more
faith in Rian Johnson then I then I
didn't call in Trevor oh I will say that
right Lucasfilm and Kathleen Kennedy
particulars seem to love him so yeah I
am exam this is another one that like
Thor after the first full trailer came
out and I went awesome I'm there and I
cut myself off from the marketing they
haven't released another one yet then I
know that they they released snippets
and likes like when I say the market I
don't just mean the trailers I mean I
don't read stories about Star Wars for
the basically since that one cannot
because I've had a lot of other things
on my plate I was I was pretty cold up
to this point like there other than
there
Empire magazine had a big thing on them
with like four different comparable
Noah's Vanity Fair I think and I got
that had a very detailed article but it
wasn't really about a plot it was more
about like the cast and a lot of it was
Carrie Fisher centric mm-hmm so I read
that but other than that like there are
there are tons of stuff about this that
I haven't seen but I know once the
trailer drops which will probably be in
early October certainly before four
comes out
yeah just November so within a month or
so it'll be out then I it will be hard
for me to say blocked box office
predictions do you think more or less
than the force awakens I don't think
it's gonna open his business yeah but I
think it'll make about the same amount
of money by the time it's done I think
you're right it probably won't open this
big it wouldn't surprise me if it makes
more all right and well we will see what
happens I think the last time I read
anything about Star Wars was when Rian
Johnson explained like he moved the scar
on kylo ren's face because where it had
been placed where where he had gotten
smashed in in other words awakens when
they tried to put a scar there and look
dumb yeah because it was like going
right across the bridge of his nose and
everything from one side of the other if
they like has heard a rough day without
even looking goofy so I just put up over
the yeah that was the last thing I read
so yeah obviously that is that is the
big one for December but there is one
other coming out and later that month
that I think is worth mentioning and
it's a movie called downsizing okay and
it's stars Matt Damon and it is set in a
not so distant future where in an
attempt to combat the rate at which
human beings are using up the world's
natural resources technology has been
created that will shrink humans down to
about five inches and that is the
solution because if we're smaller we
will consume fewer resources that's all
I know so far because there has it I
don't think there's been a full trailer
at the time of recording there's just
been a teaser and so exactly what
happens beyond that premise I don't know
much but
he's right now I'm watching the wheels
turn fry they had so many things are
just like gridlock like just jamming
together does the science of that
actually make sense
I have no one cares are they poaching
ideas from ant-man and the wasp seven
months before that movie comes out
possibly [ __ ] well it's being
directed by the guy who directed
sideways and The Descendants so this
man's never made a sci-fi movie before
and and I can't imagine it's gonna be a
particularly sci-fi be feeling movie
what would it be like to have a five
inch tall Matt Damon following you
around
that's what he sounds like in my head
that's five inches okay up on that oh
boy
so right what do you have to plug I know
you know fatherhood what yeah
you're still putting podcasts out these
are were all recorded years ago oh
you're like the jigsaw killer you plan
for your demise slowly the next episode
is gonna be about five inches tall Emma
Stone who keeps getting killed every day
recycle rebirth bike by Jake Gyllenhaal
yes yes yeah you can find me on the fire
and water podcast network several shows
on that of which the names escape me for
the moment but I have a part of that
cast it's midnight the bypass the hour
give me those Star Wars why am i doing
your plugs for you tired
also I write several web comics on
Rising Sun comics calm red and green and
my pet ninja all right you look
exhausted I'm gonna let you go
so and if you are watching this in video
you can see or not see listen to the
uncut version as a podcast on the
counsels of geeks podcast feed that's
available on iTunes and stitcher so
thanks so much for tuning in folks Thank
You Ryan for making the time
yeah I know you know so until next time
folks this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]